okay I was really hoping that the room
is emptier than it is please do ask
questions when I'm talking I usually
tend to assume that we all know stuff
that not all of us do and if you don't
ask questions I'll probably be finished
in half an hour so interrupt me ask
questions and ideally we'll go home with
something a lot of this stuff so um Who
am I I well I did computer science and
then I worked in the industry a little
bit and then I did a little bit of more
education in body informatics doing
mostly machine learning and mostly
Python and then I went back to the
industry so there was this gap of quite
a few years that I didn't realize it
happened and then I came back and now I
work as a data science consultant
somewhere here and the questions that I
had to answer where okay we have these
customers or usually you have these
questions for which you develop some
machine learning model in in academia I
would I would train my models I would
design my models and then I would test
them on my test data and then I would
publish the results of my model on the
test data and then my model is gone but
here I had these situations that okay
now I train my model but I need to serve
it in the system I have maybe an app
that sends requests on a REST API for
example and needs that those responses
in real time I couldn't use like batch
processing because I really needed those
responses in real time so I went around
and at the bunch people and I didn't
find any really good technology that
could allow me not to change much in my
codes but still says the the production
code and and the product that we have
so after asking around a little bit I
stumbled upon this pipeline IO thingy
and what's the idea the idea oh by the
way did this talk it's like tagged as
experience in PI data not because you
need to know a bunch of Python and
machine learning to understand the talk
it's because usually when you are a
little bit experienced with Python and
you're dealing with data you come up
with the questions that I didn't know
how to answer so this is like this talk
is not much about Python it's about now
that we know Python now that we know
machine learning how can we give that
save that in production so you this
thing says let's assume we have our
scikit-learn pipeline or we have our
spark ml or the tensor flow now we want
to serve it how can we make that as easy
as possible it doesn't really do it as
easy as it promises but I thought okay
my knife thought the first thought was
okay I have I have my model I have it in
memory I develop a web server with flask
maybe and then I put it behind a load
balancer and then I says is that is that
really a good solution or not I was
hoping for something better
and then here so some of these
repositories that you can go and check
out on github like one of the
repositories I have is pipeline dogs
that are my thoughts about this thing
that will help you understand a little
bit gives a little bit of context
because the documentation is lacking
every now and then there and I have
these two links to two good talks by the
main developer rock python io
they're really good and they give you an
overview of what this thing can do but
it doesn't really tell you how to make
it happen it assumes that you have your
cluster and everything running and it
shows you a bunch of codes that run I
would like to cover that part before
these talks so after that you can you
can watch these talks and understand
what you can do after so here is
conceptually what we have you have some
data coming and then you like through
some string processing you store it
sometimes you real-time want to update
your models and deploy them immediately
for the user to use them you want to
store them and do some batch processing
update your model in the background and
then deploy them and this pipeline i/o
this like these whole bunch of codes and
docker images sits in between these
modules so what is pipeline i/o it is um
a bunch of scripts that help you deploy
your cluster the docker images that
these modules that you can put on top of
each other on your cluster to to have
this thing happening and a little bit of
code that once you train your model will
save your model so let's go to the main
repository so here you have flux
capacitor is the account you have two
main repositories pipeline and source ml
in source and all you have example codes
that you can use once you have your
cluster pipeline is the repository which
has the docker files and everything that
will create this thing happening for you
if I have to
okay what it looked so what will happen
in the background we will well I don't
know like how many people here have
worked with a kubernetes cluster okay
how many people here really know what
DevOps is okay so there are a few but
not everybody I didn't know what it is
put it simply let's see let's say we
have a bunch of servers in house or on
the cloud those are a bunch of virtual
machines now we have a bunch of
resources we want something that will
handle these resources for us and we
basically sell it okay I want this
module to I want this module to take
these many resources and it will handle
okay work on which machine I can put it
I can tell this Orchestrator that okay
if if one of these services is using
this much these many resources like this
much CPU then scale it up if it's not
using it scale it down all of that goes
into the realm of having an Orchestrator
you can have PCOS you can have
kubernetes you can have open shift they
have different attributes thirdly there
are better words for different things
this one is now using kubernetes which
is one of them I have tried it on Amazon
as well as edger
and ok let's go to my script if what but
if this thing if Internet is not working
I can't really do much
No
okay
so here you see the different modules
that this system will use a lot of them
you might know know of heard of a lot of
them not one thing that I liked about
this whole project is that well it's
really under construction it goes it is
moving really quickly but it also helped
me then which module is good for what
it's not a really big closed system and
you you will have to deal with these
modules so you you kind of are forced to
learn them a bit better here you have
the documentation it is not if you go to
the website you're not necessarily
directed to these documentation so you
need to know that the actual thing is
happening in the wiki of the repository
and then you have the setup what you
need to do is you need to have it gives
you a docker image which has the
necessary tools to deploy your cluster
you need that on your machine then you
need to deploy the kubernetes on a cloud
of your choice it can be in-house and
then you deploy pipeline IO on top of
that cluster if you go through the
documentation this is like in the in the
pipeline Docs repository that I had I
have compiled the commands that I use to
like starting from getting the the
docker image to the end that is working
right now but please be worried that the
the latest release doesn't necessarily
work it's buggy that's why for example
here I'm not fetching the latest release
of the the the docker image is the
master branch so you get it
you run it and then
if you want to deploy it on Amazon you
configure your client I've done I've
done that and now let's see we can start
from here what questions yes
better
okay
yes yes it's this is the story here you
have the script but it is um it is
called something SH don't run it like
copy paste one line with one line and
see what's happening there I actually
haven't run this script as a whole so
here I say okay I want to deploy it on
on Amazon now now it is this part is a
little bit Amazon specific I need to
store the information about my cluster
somewhere if you're dealing with Amazon
you you can put it on an s3 bucket so
this is like the name it it just has to
be something does like whatever that
that is accepted by as it like a DNS
entry can be here like you can't it
can't end by dashes but it doesn't have
to be to my name and then you need to
handle your cluster you need a domain or
subdomain I didn't I'm using a free
service home that you can get a free
subdomain there I registered Python - -
now let's see what how it works okay
I'm right now I'm in my daugher I am
ready let's shoot that yeah yes okay so
I said my environment variables I'm
going to use them later then you create
your your bucket I've already done that
I'm not running that one here then you
need to like somehow you need to find
your your cluster on the internet so you
need those DNS entries is it quite a
bunch of them on Amazon you can create a
route 53 hostage zone saying meaning
that you tell Amazon that okay handle
this subdomain for me and all the
subdomains of this subdomain and tell me
what the IPS are you create that you get
some name service that you enter later
in the place that you create your
subdomains
so when you create that then you come
here and you say okay did this Amazon
thing is handl handling it for me and
then all the requests get forwarded
times on nope this is a free service
called afraid org and you can create a
whole bunch of subdomains of a whole
bunch of domains the only thing you do
here is that you create an NS record and
then you enter your name here so ideally
for your organization or for any
organization that is like seriously
deploying it for production you would
have a subdomain that you control and
then you forward that to to to to the
Amazon name service so here like if I
say now
okay I want to like ask the server about
PI data to HomeNet oh sorry
it tells you that it is handled by this
server and then whatever I create for my
cluster will be a subdomain of this
thing so you do these lines I've done
that part too once you do this then you
will see that you have a new hostage
zone here it doesn't have much yet but
it will get Scylla now I can create my
cluster if K ops so you have when you
deal with kubernetes you have cube CTL +
k ops k ops is basically to create your
clusters for you on the cloud and
especially if it's Amazon it works best
like on Microsoft I had to use their GUI
to create my closer and then continue
from there and let's create it oh I
actually have created everything on a
different region
so this come figure
okay I'll go back here
why not
what is happening
so here it does basically here you would
have used central 1a because this is the
data center that you put your nodes on
but the the bucket doesn't have to
that's why
I just have you central one
and if you go to your ex's light so if
you go to see your virtual machines
there you see the original set of valid
1a
okay
I just tried my bucket is in Europe
anyway but I I have a ready cluster just
in case that didn't work which didn't so
I'll show you that so once you want you
you create that then what you will see
in your buckets is that okay
you will have a bunch of config
configuration files about your cluster
now once you have that you can start
editing and like making sure that the
nodes are what you really need so here
for example I want at least 28 like 200
gigabytes of hard drive space there you
can set the type of the the note that
you get you can also do GPU it's a work
in progress both in terms of pipeline
i/o and kubernetes I don't have the GPU
nodes here because I ran into some of
the bugs that are still open on
kubernetes and I couldn't really do
anything about that so you set your
notes and then you say okay update my
cluster when you say update my closer it
just means that okay now check the
configuration files that you have and
make my cluster according to that
configuration and spec the first time
you will see that you don't have any
cluster anything there and your
configuration says that you need
something it will create everything for
you once you run this thing then you
will see a whole bunch of virtual
machines being created according to the
number of nodes and master nodes and
that you've decided on the master nodes
are the ones that the kubernetes master
sit on tend to note the worker nodes are
the ones that your jobs will be running
on so here I have two nodes and one
master node when you do this another
thing that is happening is that now you
are creating the discipline for your
cluster therefore instead of those two
that were there you will see
a bunch of these ones here they are
mostly I can't close this no they are
mostly internal IPS these are your
virtual private cloud IP addresses that
you can't access from outside but there
is one which is public and that's the
API dot desaad the domain that you had
now you can access this one now that you
have it there you can say ok get me my
notes this actually talks to that API
dot whatever you had and fetches the
notes that are there on your cluster
some select some of the security check
fail if some times so you can like not
not have it really secure especially
because I don't really have proper
certificates published for everything
that is supposed to be secure there we
disable that and then now now my
kubernetes cluster is ready now I can
start putting my modules on top of that
the first one is a dashboard that I can
see my cluster in a better way you're on
that and then you can view what you have
there it also show you the user path to
that dashboard and then this cluster
info will tell you what you have on your
closet that you can access one of them
is your dashboard so now you have like
it's getting a little bit better
you have your kubernetes dashboard here
it will be empty because you haven't
really deployed anything not yet
um I'm actually worried because this
thing is supposed to be running not
waiting for anything okay so now another
module that I really like is this weave
scope you can okay
so we've scope is pretty dangerous if
you did expose it to public because
whoever goes there can control your
whole cluster that's why so when you
have your kubernetes you have like when
you deploy something you have your pods
which is this like the modular thing
that like everything that needs to be
together for for service to work and
then you have your services that like
expose those services to you here I'm
only creating my basically my pods and
then on my computer I forward one of the
port's to that thing to be able to see
what's happening
and you see your closer so you see which
nodes or which pods are talking to each
other you can see your deployments and
replica sets you can upscale them if
there is too much load there and you
want to manually do that and you can
even um from anything from the pods you
can see what's going on in there you can
you can do all of these without with
scope just an easy nice GUI so now we
also have this one now we deploy the
pipeline i/o you say this is the the
latest version which is not master and
you run these two commands that will
start creating a whole bunch of
deployments on your kubernetes cluster
and create those services it is really
important to know that these two are
these two little files they are nothing
really fancy they are they basically
just say okay this Pio command is like
create it can also be deleted like you
can say this like this is the
configuration for my part create this
thing you can also say okay delete this
thing you don't have to know what it was
there and if you want to restart
something delete create then you come
here and you're like okay I just want to
I don't need any radius key-value server
there you just delete that one or you
don't create it some of these now that I
will continue are again not the latest
version or the master um and here you
have the services so now once you do
this one this is when you come here and
you see all your pods and services and
now you have your spark you have HDFS
you have well what do we have here you
have your like prediction service you
have a Jupiter hope you have turbine and
hystrix unlike two of my favorites there
and you have
airflow so okay now we have our cluster
how do we how do we deal with different
versions of our machine learning modules
now you can either these prediction
servers expose the Knife API for you
that you can push your model to them and
they will immediately start sharing that
model you can version them if you have
somebody using them you say okay now I
have version two and then you change
they change the URL and they immediately
start changing using division two if you
want to do a/b testing you push two
different versions and then you do your
a be testing there the it they use
specially on the java part okay before
that my question my original question
was how can I like was it like what did
a good idea to just put my web server in
Python and put a load balancer behind
that one answer is no some of it some
people answer to that question yes
people who say no go different paths one
of them is this JPM ml or piano now
which is a language for you to serialize
your model you can serialize your model
from R from Python like the scikit-learn
ones or SPARC ml once you see realize
your model then your model is there a
different language can you can
understand this file now can save it and
then you have a Java Scala code which
saves that model for you this is a so
this part that will use when you save
your model you're using these libraries
but the part that serves you the model
using these files and the servers that
expose those ApS for you for you to push
the models or pipeline IO now
[Music]
so let's go through some of them and see
how it looks you may be able to access
this one now under Jupiter Hub PI data
on home network I have the pardon I
sorry again but you will see so this
this one is exposed to you now I'll
probably delete everything tonight but
you now you can check it and probably
won't work if everybody does but you
will so this is what you'll see again
when you deploy your own thing you will
see a bunch of these folders but not
source ml and this uplink thingy these
are old codes don't work with the
current service you need to use this
that these codes all the example codes
that I mentioned are in a different
repository under the same account as
flux capacitor there are source ml so
now you have deployed your cluster you
are using these codes and the one that
we'll be using mostly are things that
are very close to the codes that you
find here you have examples for spark
scikit-learn
like pure Python server or PMML and also
tens also so let's go through some of
them and see how it works
do you know Jupiter hub that that part
is not know right you know you know yeah
this is just that like also a vision
fans here well first you need this
package which dumps your scikit-learn
pipelines in PMML and then let's have
some dummy models feed my model
and after you feed your model this is
basically what you do you dump your
model in a PMML file which looks like
this we have both so here in pipeline IO
you have the PMML server which is the
Java server which uses hystrix and
turbines which are like some Netflix on
Netflix uses them they are really
reliable I really like that but you also
have the Python Python server that you
can pickle your scikit-learn and send it
but in in the case so if I was using
like Jeep I did like Gaussian process
I'll probably use that but if I was
using scikit-learn you can you can dump
your whole scikit-learn pipeline in P
animal so you don't really have to do
the Python way so you can like this is
um no this is not yeah this is what it's
doing this is like a scikit-learn model
and it's dumping it in plan in PMML so I
have my file the other thing that I need
you don't really need it it just makes
things easier you have this Python
package Pio CLI what you can do with it
is for example you say okay I have this
server I want to deploy a PMML model in
this namespace this is mine the name of
the model version 1 and my model is
located here
okay now you say deployed it just when
you look at it what it's doing is that
it compresses the whole thing that you
have in your folder and sends it to the
server now sir your server has a copy of
your code and your model and everything
you had there so you better not have
your data in that folder because then
that would be large but you're sending
everything meaning that if you have
different versions on your server later
on you can go back to your server and
see okay this model was that this code
was actually for this model it's not it
like that it's no way a good way of
version controlling your models but just
to keep track of okay what model was for
which for which code for now it's a good
solution and then you can use this same
thing to get a prediction of your model
so you send it an input and you then you
get your output now you have you have
you you have your server which is
serving your pure machine learning model
here are those api's you don't have to
use it if you're writing a code it's as
easy as sending a request you're sending
a post request to that server
and it gives you the response and it's
also pretty fast I'm not too bad that's
sent 2,000 requests and then the other
thing you have if you use this PMML with
it like history's on the back end then
you can see for each of your models that
you've deployed you can see how much
look is under
okay took 11 seconds for those 2000 ones
and here you'll see that okay my 99th
percentile is 300 millisecond but when
90th percentile is one millisecond it
was probably because at the beginning
was loading your model from the file
okay questions until now zoom you can't
really abstract away all the I'm
assuming you can't really abstract way
all the deployment stuff that's going on
so for example for instance is there
fault tolerance in there and how does
the Reg out of the registry for
individual model instances work huh
that's one part of the West remember
I'll just put the other one right after
it like you can choose you can choose
which one to rather you can answer both
of you want and the other question is is
there any component in there if you have
two models for example predicting you
know the same stuff and you want to
maybe have two different you know
aspects of it and you have some sort of
it's a strategy how to mix the results
stuff like that you know support they're
all or said something that's out of
scope and you have to build something
extraction in front of it so the second
question which is about using different
models is basically what you do in
machine learning using on sound methods
it does it's not in the scope of
pipeline io you do machine learning for
that but for the first one the
reliability scalability and the
deployment this is not the preferred way
in production for anybody because right
now I could push I basically did now
push the the model on on what I had on
my server over I just override my model
on the server so you don't really want
to do that in production what you want
to do is that you
you know in software so the problem with
machine learning legwork I think is the
problem is that the whole machine
learning thing is maybe I don't know 10
to 20 years behind software development
in terms of continuous integration and
vision control and all of that so what
you do here is that you would push I
would push my model into a repository
and then use that repository to build a
docker image and then push that docker
image as a new service to your cluster
and then your production environment
uses these different services and then
if you don't like one of them you just
take them down and you have that like
you have basically the history of all
the docker images that you've had and
that's the that's the the main idea for
having it in production and that's like
partially why the other service that you
have in pipeline IO pair which is like
one of the modules that it uses is this
airflow you can define processes in air
so you can say I can attach this process
to a github webhook
and then you say ok if something happens
on this branch of this repository on
github start creating my docker image
then push it to the cluster and then
have it ready and running and like the
kind of code that you need to write for
your air flow if it loads is not that
hard this is like if this process would
be one page of code you don't have to
use this one you can use your Jenkins
because basically from now on you have
everything that you have in in software
development you have your cluster you
have your repositories you could use
Jenkins to to create your new images and
push push push them in the cluster what
in terms of reliability and the one I
like is um that this history is because
you can configure it and say ok I really
want my response time to be less than I
don't know 10 milliseconds 20
milliseconds and it doesn't wait for for
if you send the request to one of the
workers and that worker is taking too
much time it just sends that same
request to another one because the pot
the policy is
here too like to get that result at
least once and pretty quickly not
exactly once but you don't really care
if you end up sending the same request
to two different workers and you can
again that's like what you have when you
have any Orchestrator you can set
policies for if the CPU usage of these
services more than this on all the nodes
just scale it up does that answer the
question okay so this is PMML I like it
a lot of people don't and now let's see
if we can get
okay yeah I like this one this answers
your question about Python so let's say
now I have a really a custom model it's
like this is supposed to calculated set
score for you and I don't have this so
once you have a code which is not
supported by by those PMML libraries you
have two ways to go one is to write that
thing for PMML yourself like be it like
basically add to like add to those PML
libraries okay I want to be able to dump
this model now extend that or you can
just pickle your your model and then
send it to the other server on Python
i/o which access just Python code and
it's not the Java based one anymore okay
now I have my file and then again to
deploy it you just send it to a
different server so another thing these
services you will you need to know where
they are these these little URLs or
server addresses that I'm using here
this is how you get them so what
services do I have a whole bunch of them
umm tell me what like prediction Python
is one of the values there is your
server address and then you copy that
into here to push your model there and
you deploy which again compresses
everything you have and sends it to the
server again this this Pio thingy is
nothing really complicated it is using
those api's so you could just ignore all
of that and have your own code which is
talking to that API endpoint
which is accepting the zipped files for
your models something really useful
there too to understand how those
servers are working is we have the
pipeline itself
in CLI you have this Pio and like you
can say okay what happens if I deploy
and then which deploy is it there so
this code is supposed to also in the
future deployed manage your cluster
deployment and then you don't have to
run those kubernetes commands but then
in case of deploying your model you'll
see what API endpoint point of the
server it's using okay so we sent the
model there now we can get it back
you
yes
so this is the output and then you can
see okay what happens again you can you
don't have to use that command line and
you can see what happens if you send
like a thousand one's not too bad so
this is now covering the PMML way and
the just Python which are two different
services now you can go and see okay
what about tensorflow
again it's it like usual tensorflow
stuff you train your model once you
train your model you send it to a server
this is the limit of this talk and
pipeline i/o now because you can on on
the cluster I can train it I can push it
and when you get the one to get the
prediction the HTTP server on the server
can't talk to the the Google protocol
and there is a bug there so I can train
it and push it on but I can't get the
predictions here but the code is almost
there like that the server is almost
there
and you can see how it works questions
Pat line
it is so the thing is if you want if you
really want to have those modules that
you have here on a kubernetes cluster
it's not really that easy you could do
it you have them here already if you
want to serve your models that piece of
code that is reading your dumps that
that you're sending to the server and
it's serving you on HTTP and giving you
the predictions using the code that you
sent to the server that part is
completely portable that is that is the
part that you have in predictions you
have okay my JVM is the one that handles
part line I oh sorry the p-n ml and here
you have evaluate PMML command it
basically reads the file and the input
uses that model that you sent it applies
it on your input and gives you the
output tornado so flask is much easier
to use but that that's again like what
is that at the beginning when I said
like I learn a lot of stuff here is that
fast is not asynchronous but it's really
easy to to write a piece of code using
it and have your observer immediately
ready but if you want to do like
asynchronous stuff then you use tornado
and it uses that yes oh yes oh you don't
deploy new servers you you upscale
you're on pot or pure service basically
so here
one of the services that you have is
prediction Python 3 and then if I get
its part you see that I have only one
out of one that I've requested you can
upscale it and you can say ok once free
service there then you have three you
can say dynamically scale it up and down
and if you if your whole cluster doesn't
support it like you don't have enough
resources there then you add a note then
that's when you go like go back one step
at the very beginning when I was
defining my cluster before deploying
kubernetes on like on it I said okay I
want to worker nodes and one master node
you say ok one now three worker knows
one four and then after you do that you
say ok one more of these pots on top of
that
from a force on a scale from like zero
you'd be totally crazy to run this to
ten iBM has been running this for ten
years successfully like what do you
think where is this stuff I don't know
of any any enterprise company running it
I know that there are beta users and I
know that for one of our customers will
be adapting this for their back-end so I
wouldn't I wouldn't so for that solution
I would like use whatever I have here
and then I what I have to do is for an
enterprise to have it like they prefer
to have it on openshift instead of
kubernetes they wanted to have it on Red
Hat on instead of Debian but I would use
it and then the other thing is that I
wouldn't I won't be using all the
services so I can focus on fixing and
making some of them very stable and then
using them thing is for for some for
some of them the solutions that I see
out there are pretty closed like
tensorflow says you can train stuff and
I also have tensile so saving which is
pretty reliable but I have to do my
stuff in tensorflow the other solutions
are like that apache spark says that
okay I have spark ml you can save your
models there using micro batches you
have these different solutions but if I
have a group of data scientists that are
used to their Python I couldn't really
find any other solution that would serve
them here I just tell them whatever they
want to do they don't so that the other
beauty is that they don't your
prediction you're serving cluster
doesn't have to be the same as your
training closer you can just have them
on different ones they're just if these
endpoints that they're talking to each
other they don't you don't they don't
your data scientists don't even need to
train their models on your cluster they
can train them on their machines and
then at the end use this to push their
models so I think I would use them but
not all of it and it's not stable that's
like like for example one one thing is
that the results that we saw from those
servers
they are not even proper JSON doesn't
matter doesn't go but but there is like
there is a like for example there is a
tiny bug that in the return values it's
not that easy to handle JSON in like
Scala or Java and like that's not
implemented yet so these are really
things that you need to know but after
that fear it's like it's it's not so the
thing is it's not much on top of the
modules that you can rely on I can rely
on turbine and hystrix I can rely on my
spark I can rely on my HDFS it's not I
can't rely on a kubernetes cluster it's
like it's not much more than that and
the part that is developed by pipeline
IO developers is not that much yeah
thank you
one complication of running real-time
prediction in production is of course
access to a data so as far as I
understood right now you're pushing the
features in a JSON file so you're not
accessing any outside storage is a
pipeline your comes with any options
already embedded or it's up to me to
connect it to either event strains like
Kafka Genesis or two maybe no sequel
database like dynamo or [ __ ] does it
help with access of so one is that if
your prediction is just data like key
value you want to know what are the top
five choices of your users you push that
look to your key value server and you
fetch it from there instead of having a
prediction and you use your machine
learning model to create that for you
every night for example where if you're
out on you update that a new production
environment actually queries that
database but if your model needs
real-time access to data for its
prediction then you need to go and
modify those prediction servers what I
would recommend and I would like to use
it for is that that module that is
sending a request to my model to get a
prediction fetch all the data that it
requires to get that prediction sends it
to my model and then my model uses that
information because your model is your
trained model your I mean when you have
like a support vector machine when you
have a neural network you get your input
and then you have your output it's not
that you're you give you say like okay
my model this is my image classify this
for me your model doesn't go query a
database for you to be able to classify
that image for you if that is the case
if that your use case you need to modify
those prediction servers alright thank
you
[Applause]